to me I have a lot of young black men
that follow me there's no way on Earth
I'm going to let them believe that they
have a lesser chance than anybody else
if they just work their ass off there's
no I'm not on their dreams like
that I'll be damn you call me a racist
if you want you call me a racist all day
I'm not I don't care there's no way I'm
letting those young man believe that
100 because I know plenty of black
guys look King rich is here right now
winner all day long cuz he didn't let
that happen 100% but we have to
work hard that's about what about all of
our friends that are black that are very
very successful do people listen to you
when they see looking at racism is for
broke people no bottom line